That's a lie. Mr. Link,
>> sorry. Good to meet you, Shamsi. One
second. Sorry.
>> Nice to meet you as well.
>> Hello, Shamsi.
>> Hello. How are you?
>> Good to meet you. I wanted to ask you
something. Uh, I noticed you have a
tooth that's silver. Is that halal? Is
that Is that uh halal by Islam?
>> No, it's not silver. as gold.
>> But you're not supposed to wear gold,
right?
>> No, you're not supposed to wear gold,
but to put it out of necessity
>> like for your teeth or your nose,
>> then you allow it because there's a
narration in Sah Bkari, one of the
prophet's companion broke his nose in
the wall. So the messenger of Allah
wasallam said, "Put uh gold out of
necessity because gold is stronger and
it lasts longer."
>> I see. Okay, that makes sense. Are you
are you Muslim?
>> Uh well, it's complicated.
>> It's complicated.
>> Who are you then? What do you mean it's
complicated? I'm not asking you about uh
which year you got married or you had a
child.
>> Well, it's complicated, man, because I I
was raised Muslim, but I kind of lost uh
I lost hope. I had a lot of things
happen that kind of made me feel a
little bit bitter towards God, you know,
>> and and so I kind of I kind of fell away
from Islam.
>> You want see the problem, brother, you
wanted God that fulfill your desires,
fulfill what you want,
>> you know, I mean like the problem here
is that you you you are utilizing
emotional argument against God. God is
not here to please you. We are here to
please God. God does whatever he wishes
within his creation. All right? I mean,
you're not bitter than prophet Muhammad.
Prophet Muhammad wasallam, he lost his
he lost his father, he lost his mother,
then his uncle was taking care of him,
he lost his uncle, then he lost his
wife, then he lost his children, his
sons, you know, then he got kicked out
from his own town, then he was
oppressed, then he was to then his own
comp sorry, his own companies were
tortured, he was harmed. And he never
said ah God then no because Allah taught
us this life is a test. I went through a
lot of hardship. Allah I went a lot of
test. Alhamdulillah say always
alhamdulillah because I can see there's
lot of blessings which God has given me.
Some people don't have it. But Satan
always like to utilize emotional
argument to try people away from God. If
God doesn't want to give you nothing,
does not negate God's existence or God
deserves to be woripped. You understand?
>> Yeah.
>> You understand my brother?
>> Yes, I understand. It's just uh I feel
like uh sometimes I feel like there is I
don't feel the love of God,
you know? I don't feel like God loves
me. You understand?
>> Are you paying for the oxygen that you
you're breathing in?
>> No, I'm not paying for it. So if God
hates you, he would tell you to pay for
it.
>> You get it for free.
>> No, you're right. You're right.
>> Okay, let me listen to this. Listen to
this, brother. You know, imagine you are
in your own room. Oh, I have one. Yes.
Imagine tonight you go to your own
house. You about to sleep in your own
room and you go sleep. You wake up in
the middle of the night and there's a
fire everywhere in your own room and you
try your best to save yourself. You
couldn't. And I came and I saved your
life. What would you say to me at least?
>> Thank you.
>> Would you remember me all the time?
>> Yes,
>> of course. I saved your life. But guess
what? What about God who gave your life
for free? Why are you not grateful to
him? I never gave your life. I just
saved something you have. But yet you'll
be very grateful to me and you won't
thank me all the time. So you you
brother, you have many blessings, but
you don't appreciate it. We have many
blessings. That's why go to the
hospital, brother. Go see how many
people they that unable to go to the
bathroom by themselves. They need to get
help. But yet they still are grateful to
God. They still appreciate God for what
they have, you know. So remember the
blessings here. Not only look the
prophet Noah, prophet Noah for many
years, prophet Jacob, Jacob, prophet Job
Aub Allah tried him, you know. So
brother, I went through hardship. It was
very tough for over a decade hardship.
Not like one year hardship, over a
decade hardship. But I never gave up on
Allah because I I what I did I
understood that Allah deprived me from
something but I looked at it. It could
be good for me. You understand? But I
always looked at the other things which
Allah blessed me with. You understand?
My own existence, your own existence by
the virtue of Allah. You understand? And
this life that Allah mentioned is a
test. Allah will test us through our
wealth, our health, our families. So
this is the life like and it shows you
here brother imagine Allah chose uh
prophets of his. He chose Moses, Jacob,
Isaac, Jesus, Muhammad. Yet he still
test them and he put them through
hardship. Because God putting you
through hardship does not mean he
doesn't love you. Allah said in the
Quran
is the
Allah said will Allah after his swore by
time that Allah said if Allah blessed
someone with something he said indeed
Allah love me and if Allah put someone
through hardship he will say oh Allah
hates me Allah said nay there's the
criteria Allah can put someone through
hardship and and the messenger of Allah
wasam told us if Allah loves someone
will put him through hardship because in
the narration the messenger of Allah
wasam said on the day of resurrection
they will bring someone all his life is
miserable all his life but he was a
believer in God then they will put him
into paradise and they will ask him oh
so and so have you ever tested any
hardship ship. You say never. Even me,
my brother, I told you I went through
hardship over a decade. Now Allah
removed the hardship for me. Wah, I look
back as if never happened.
So yeah, I think the gratitude is a big
problem. You know, I try to remind
myself all the time to be grateful for
everything I got. I'm married, I got
kid, I got wife, you know, I got parents
are still alive. I have a lot to be
thankful for. And so I don't think I
have ever forgotten about God. It's just
that uh uh sometimes the darkness is so
strong that like I I have a hard time to
even uh feel grateful for anything
because it's
>> I understand what you're saying. Sorry
to cut you. Forgive me for interrupting.
You know, not long ago I've listened a
very nice talk by our teacher which he
took it from one of the scholars.
He said the reason some people they fell
when they go through hardship because
they don't have the tools to face those
hardship and you're right because you
don't have the tool of true iman true
faith understanding what is the purpose
of the creation reading the Quran and
when you have that those tools piety and
righteousness and you understand the
purpose of life then hardship will
become very very light on you when you
understand that you know the last person
for God to put to put you through
hardship and you not be the last person
when you understand that when God put
you through hardship doesn't mean you
hate you because God put his loved ones
like prophet Moses, prophet Muhammad
through hardship. So hardship does not
mean straight away God hates you. Rather
hardship sometimes make us understand
who are our real friends. Make us
understand and appreciate what we had
before. Like for example, Adam, prophet
Adam, Allah put him through hardship,
which is Allah put him through a test.
So because he fell the test, Allah took
him out from paradise and he put him
into upon this earth. He said one of the
wisdom for Adam to appreciate paradise.
So if he stays upon righteousness, his
reward will be paradise. So when Allah
will take him back to paradise, he will
appreciate paradise more and more. So
hardship hardship brother like I
mentioned makes you stronger and God
will test you brother even your own
mother if you tell her I love you I love
you she's going to test you say okay you
keep telling me I love you when it's
easy for you now when it's hardship you
telling you back for me so Allah will
test us Allah said in the Quran
Allah says do the people think they will
say we believe and Allah will not test
them verely Allah will test them like he
tested those who came before them in
order for Allah's knowledge to manifest
and to see who is a truthful and who was
a liar who was truthful in his belief
and who was a hypocrite in his belief so
brother you have children many people
would have no children. You have a
parents, many people have no parents.
Mashallah, you're looking healthy. You
know, you have a car, you so do not let
the Satan utilize the hardship to turn
you away from God. Because like I said
to you, Satan is our enemy and Satan, he
knows that some of us in hardship we are
very very weak. So what he does, he will
utilize the hardship us away from God.
But as in Arabic language, they say
How many hardship became blessings?
>> Yeah, you're right. You're right. There
are many things in life that have made
me feel uh stronger because I went
through it, you know. And I I look back
and I definitely agree with you. There
are times that if I didn't go through
that, I probably wouldn't be strong in
certain things that I am today. It's
just uh you know when you live uh uh
when you live in the west and you are
surrounded by all of this information
and people and uh people are not that uh
nice uh it kind of uh makes you uh
miserable too you know and uh
the culture in America is very uh just
empty there's no soul you know and so uh
you are trying to remain a good person
But at the same time you feel like uh
there is people around you that are not
good people. So you you try to do your
best and sometimes it's it's very strong
but like you said it's a lot of it is
emotional because we allow the emotions
to control our thought
>> you know instead of thinking about uh
God. Um but I I'm I'm trying I'm trying
my best you know. I'm trying my best.
Right brother, what we say to you, you
know, the pro the there is like there's
some blessings in the western world like
you know life is easy in terms of you
know if you want to go to the hospital,
you want to go to uh buy a car, you
know, however we have abandoned the most
important thing which is there's
something within us. Nothing can fulfill
it. No money, no beautiful woman, no
beautiful car, nothing except when you
understand your purpose of life and when
you have connection to the creator of
the heavens and the earth and the wishes
in between them. Brother, I prison. When
I in prison 05, 2005, I in prison when I
was in prison, brother, I was praying
day and night for Allah to take me out
of prison, you know. And I done one I
got two years, I done a year. Yeah. So
the in my case the trial was going for
nearly six months my trial. Yeah. So I'm
praying hard to God to take me out and
but
God did not take me out. So I got my
sentence my sentence I done a year. I
did a year then I came out. When it came
when I came out I came out very strong.
So I said, "Subhan Allah, Allah is our
Lord and he's he's in control of
everything." Sometimes we want something
right now, but it's not good for us
right now.
You know, it's not good for you right
now. God knows what is the best time for
you to have it or not to have it. So I
because I used to, you know, I was
involved in crimes and drugs and
everything. Yeah. So I thought I said
imagine when I in prison I came out the
first two weeks or the first month
probably I will go back to my old ways
but because I stayed longer so my iman
become stronger so when I come out
prison alhamdulillah it was Ramadan as
well so I start practicing more you know
alhamdulillah so how many how many times
bro we are looking for something or
asking something from God and we don't
have it because God knows what is the
best time for us But because we are
people that we desire things so quick,
we want everything quick. Especially the
time we living in, the time we living
in, in your own house, you have a phone,
you order food, everything is fast. So
you want you want God to give you
everything fast. No, no, no, brother.
God is he knows everything about
creation. One of the scholars said when
God doesn't give me something, I'm very
happy because he he said I know that
thing if he was good for me, God will
give it to me. But because he never gave
it to me, I will know he's not good for
me. When you have a true belief in God,
alhamdulillah, Islam is not based upon a
blind faith. When I say true belief in
God, doesn't mean just believe anything.
No, Islam is based upon rational
arguments, tangible arguments. You
understand? So, so what I would say to
you, bro, that the the the the hardship
is one of the the tools that Satan can
use against people, but also can be a
tools for us to reflect upon our
situation, reflect upon our soul,
reflect upon our actions and say, you
know what, I need to turn back to God.
Because this life, brother, how long you
going to live? How long going to live?
100 years, bro, we going to die and
we're going to turn back to return back
to God. And the eternal life either is
paradise or the hellfire because Allah
is the most just based upon his mercy
create paradise based upon his mighty
and his anger create the hellfire.
However, he gave you and I free will for
us to choose in this life. Cuz you talk
about hardship then the worst hardship
is to be in the hellfire forever. So if
you hate hardship then utilize the
hardship of this life as a means for you
to enter paradise.
>> Thank you brother. Thank you. I
appreciate your words. I'm going to
think about them. I need to process
this. Um I really needed to hear that.
So thank you.
If you can send me a private message
I'll give you my number and we can stay
in contact if you have any question.
>> Thanks man. I appreciate you, brother.
I've listened to you over the years and
um just wanted opportunity to talk to
you. Thank you so much. You've uh you
really uh made me uh realize some
things. Um you know, it's uh it's not uh
very uh common for me to have a chance
to speak to somebody who can uh uh who
can tell me these things. So I um I'm
definitely going to think about what you
said. I thank you so much.
>> So So your family are Muslims?
>> Yeah, I'm Bosnian.
I'm Bosnia. Bosian refugee. Yeah, I was
an immigrant uh from Bosnia, but you
know, I I've I've had to move around a
lot as a refugee. So, like it was kind
of a crazy life, but um you know, but
>> to brother, what we say to you? Sorry to
cut you. Look, bro. So, so you left
Islam completely or you just pray?
>> No, I I didn't I don't think I
>> You believe in Allah. You believe
Prophet Muhammad?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I don't think I ever left uh
uh God you know I just uh you know there
it's just uh like times where I just
feel very distant from God you know and
so
>> is it time you turn back brother prayer
advice to you prayer prayer bro look
yeah I was just speaking to my wife
yesterday I said to her certain things I
was going through hardship in my life so
I was I thought you know what no way I'm
going to win this case or that case. But
because I put trust in Allah and I know
everything is in the hand of Allah
doesn't mean I'm strong all the time
brother I'm a human being like you
sometimes I get weak as well but I
always remind myself that Allah is in
control of everything and one of the
things that helped me a lot listen to
the Quran the Quran wallah is a cure if
you understand it and reflect upon it
one of the best ways prayer and the
Quran these two tools wai I use in my
life alhamdulillah I went through
hardship many hardship. Alhamdulillah.
I'm stay firm, stay strong by the
permission of God.
>> God bless you. Uh
>> thank you brother.
uh said which recer do you prefer
I liked a I don't know if you know
my sisters
I show you who I listen to
and I used to listen to this chapter a
lot my dear brothers and sisters one of
the Best thing, best tool that you can
utilize when you go through hardship.